こんにちははじめしゃちょーね皆さん今日は報告というかコースらせというかはそんな
感じの動画ですよろしくお願い致しますみなさんね
ポイントカードを持ってますかあの僕でねーなーはっきりましょうポイントカード第8
位ですなぜかというと財布がかさばるからなんで僕基本的にポイントカードとか持た
ないんですけども唯一私が持っているポイントカード
ポンタカードてものがあります後6年使ってでもポロポロなんですけど知ってると言い
ますかね
ロードの近くなる人はみんな使っていると思うんですけども ponta カードと
いうカードがあるんですよ僕このカードだけなぜか持ってまして
ポイントカード以来の僕が玉田はローソンがバイトしてた時期があってその時作って
もらったやつがこれなんですけどずっと使って使って作って作って使う
言ってましてあの祭神
し付いてしまいました私はじめ車窓
ローソンで
100倍に使ってましたーーー
その題名の通りで100万円コンビニで買い物してました ponta カードの
仕組みなんですけども
100万円体やばくね俺一体何を買ってどうやってそんな100倍も使ったんだって話
になるんですけどそこでもなんで100万円湖面で使ったがわかったって言うとあの本
たカートって100円分買い物すると1ポイント食べるんですよ他にもいろんな食べ方
があるんですけどもね
ってそんなもんであの最近ポイント脳活が9900何ポイントあるなぁと思っている親
ば嫌だと思って丁寧さんもいいみたいな他のローソンとか言ったかってカードピって
やると計算がうってなるぐらいけっこうすごいぽいと思っております
9.9100ちょいっぽいなああつって待機月2回ほどとってレシート見てみると一番
ポイント超えていました
100円で1ポイントつくんで一番ポイント貯めるためには口単純計算100万円対応
しなきゃいけないという傷になるで100万円ローソンで使っていることが分かりまし
た
そんだけまあそんなゲット5ためやばいんじゃね結構安全4000ポイントとかいるん
ですよたまに
めちゃくちゃローソン作ってる人とか3.4千ぽいの太い腕ってかもうたぶんね
一応ちょいと行ってる人はねそんないないと思うんだよなぁ
いたら恥ずかしいですけどねいたら恥ずかしいんですけど一番ポイントはヤバいと思っ
たば今度ポイントランキングとか出ないかな
中島ツイッター見たんですけど多く中で7000ポイントとかの人居ますねまあまあ
すごいですよ正直7000ポイントもやばいする70万円目のお買い物ですからねで僕
を本ティアードローソンでしか使わないねおそらくローソンの買い物のみで同じ
ポイントが貯まったんだと
思います100万円お買い物した記念にね ponta カーズをスマホに映ってたん
でちょっと写してみたんですけど
こちらですねポイントが一番31ポイントでございますじゃあまずほど家の近くに
ローソンがあるんですけども基本ねぼくそこでしか回もしないんですよさっきだかあの
ポイントなりずつ見てるとやっぱニっぽいんととか10ポイント2ポイントから10
ポイントの買い物ほぼ
もう1日123海外行っててマジでも日々の積み重ねでここまできたのかなと思って
おります
コンビニで100万円使ってしまいましたえーどうするこれねポンタポイントいろんな
使い道があるみたいなんですけどもなんかもう
[音楽]
同氏は何に使うかなわせハサミと唱えながらいろんなローね ponta 辺の
ず一方飛んだが1616ポイントを言ってました逆に今だけポイントあるとへ
こんな世界があるのかこういうすごい代走ダイソンの洗濯機とか窓がポイントで打って
ますねやってやばやばい
それもなんか5番6番ポイントとか全然まだまだ先はだけなおい
俺ひょっとして大したことない俺大したことないかもしれないのは不安になってきた
part 3するキャリーキャリーキャリーケースを変えますよえ待って待っておれ
大したもないのか
おったポイント貝取大したことない寄与してきたので待ったより大丈夫じゃないのかな
本命で地道に何年も頑張って食べた一番ポイント大したことないのかな
たまに使ったりするんですよね食べない時とかたまにポッドポイントでコンビニで
買い物とかしちゃうそこで多分差がついて気がしますね
入ってまってなんか
すげーことしたなと思ってたけどそうでもない気がしてきましたわからない何かね
こんなガード下用とかでも対応してるからひょっとしてなんかコンビニでやるのは
あまり行くんじゃね雪があるね
[音楽]
えまとりあえずあのコンビニで100万円ぐらい買い物してるのはもうまぎれもない
事実だと思うんで僕コンビニ大好きなんですよ俺だけ皆さんに気を伝えたかった
コンビニ大好きすぎてコンビニでコンビニで毎日毎日買い物をしているとポンタカード
のポイントは100万円分くらいすぐ貯まりようってお話をしたかったわけでござい
ますみなさんのこんなカードは何ポイントたまっているのでしょうか
よかったらぜひ確認してみてください
では次回は2万ポイントでお会いしましょうじゃあな
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
じゃあなー
まずすごい人なんぽになるんだろう